très concentré devant sa tablette cette
adolescente tentent de suivre son cours
de maths en direct malgré l'agitation
qui l'entouré des soignants membres du
rectorat des kiwanis se pressent autour
d'elle et de cet outil expérimental
on appelle cela le cartable numérique
connecté six seulement sont déployés
dans toute la france et pour cet enfant
coupé de ses amis depuis des mois ce
n'est que du bonheur moi je trouve que
c'est génial qu'on puisse faire ça pour
les enfants puissent hospitalisés et qui
ne peuvent pas aller à l'école pour
l'instant j'étais très triste de ne pas
pouvoir aller à l'école est de ne pas
voir mes camarades mais quand j'ai vu ça
mais pour la première fois j'ai vu mes
camarades j'ai vu mon école c'est comme
si je suis dans la casse mais ce cri la
caméra qui me remplace michel of vite à
l'hôpital depuis la rentrée ou une
malformation du dos l'a subitement privé
de l'usagé de ses jambes
entre soins et rééducation elle suit son
programme de 3e grâce à ce nouvel outil
connecter avec une puce 4g à tout moment
la communication est possible l'enfant
peut participer à une séance de qu avec
des enfants normaux dans une salle de
classe normale et elle ne gagne pas
uniquement dans le soin avec le soutien
de son professeur à l'hôpital l'enfant
peut désormais mieux préparer son
passage en seconde mais pour les
soignants il y à beaucoup plus de gros
progrès thérapeutique l'envi de vivre et
de se battre à nouveau je peux ici
témoigner c'est une autre ils se sont
beaucoup mieux et ça se voit elle se
sent beaucoup mieux ça se voit ça
s'entend je ne peux pas vous dire plus
compte tenu du dossier
car n'y croyez moi on passé de l'ombre
au jour j avance beaucoup pouvaient
comme ça quand jusqu'en comme je suis
hospitalisée pour l'instant je vais pas
rater beaucoup l'école est comme ça ça
va me permettre d'avancer pour mon
projet
le rêve de cette collégienne retrouver
bien sûr un jour sa mobilité et devenir
plus tard chirurgienne pour soigner les
enfants